[Music]
hello I'm Karen Gillen hi I'm Tom
clementieff hi I'm Will Poulter hello
I'm chakuri wuji I'm James Gunn I'm Sean
Gunn and I'm Chris Pratt and we're here
to take a quiz about uh see uh like how
much we know about the MCU right we got
the MCU yeah right yeah
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
rocket asks for three things when they
are trying to escape prison which is not
one of those things there's a prosthetic
leg a map of the prison a guard's
armband and a battery map of the prison
no no oh
yeah he needs the battery he needs the
armband to access yeah
correct correct all right James why
don't you just sit this one out okay
yeah you're dragging us down which one
of these actors makes their MCU debut in
Captain America the Winter Soldier in
2014. Elizabeth Olsen has won the
maximoff Tom Hiddleston as Loki done at
Guerrera as Okoye or Benedict Wong as
Wong is it deny no no it's not no it's
too early I think it was Elizabeth
foreign
[Applause]
and Thor Ragnarok who does Thor fight in
the arena while stuck in the car we all
know this this is Hulk it's Hulk Hulk
Hulk
yep correct which of these Stanley
cameos happens in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 well that's easy an
astronaut for sure Marvel astronaut
how'd you know that one yeah
which of these characters does disappear
after thanos's snap
Rogers
an Avengers end game which infinity
stone does Natasha sacrifice herself
full so wolf
I don't know wait
um
no clue
Natasha sacrifices herself
Charlotte Scarlett
plays Natasha yeah oh oh black widow's
name's Natasha right you should see one
of the movies sometimes
wait wait wait no no no no no no because
the Soul Stone wasn't that when Thanos
threw Gamora Gamora off someone that you
love is that not the same thing but it's
the same thing it's like that's right
that's Thanos trying to get it yeah
whereas The Avengers trying to get it
yeah so it would be whatever that same
stone is I thought they both got the
same Stone yes audiences realities oh
yeah okay so on three two one so yeah
hey yeah there you go in Hawkeye what
does Elena cook for Kate when she breaks
into her apartment okay we don't know
that I watched her I I just saw that
yeah it's um it's macaroni cheese right
it's macaroni cheese yeah okay
mac and cheese
oh let's go and finally in Spider-Man no
way home which version of Spider-Man
successfully saves MJ after she falls
off a building Toby Maguire Spider-Man
Garfield Spider-Man marble Sony Tom
Holland Spider-Man Marvel are you just
saying marbles
he's reading Marvel Sony mg is not in
Tom Holland's world right yes she is oh
what she is is that Sunday yes
I think it's Toby in this movie though
what's going on Toby let's go out on
Toby okay three come on
[Music]
[Applause]
basically we probably would have done
better if it wasn't for Chris for sure
that's the main takeaway here well I
thought we did pretty good 93 is pretty
good that's an A minus that's like the
best grade I've ever got and I didn't
contribute to any of the answers but I'm
going to take some of the credit that's
great that's right out the question
really well thank you appreciate that
especially Marvel Sony
go see Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
it's in theaters now well I don't know
when this is coming out but it's in
theaters May 5th May 5th and if it's May
5th or later that's now I nailed that
foreign